so i went to this cave right
so there's this thing if you go to
kentucky
and there is a cave there because i've
been trying to be more outgoing
when i don't want to do something i go
do it um
the other day i didn't want to go to jiu
jitsu went over to nashville mma
left out of there feeling like a champ
you know some
this lady put me in a sugar lock once
you know and i can't i still can't feel
two of my toes and i can't wink out of
one of my eyes but
god's plan bruh um
what else am i talking about here uh
what are we saying
man my mind gets all rattly um
oh i went in a cave they got caves over
there
and a cave is just basically like a um
it's kind of like a mountain but like i
made out of air
and so i went over when
i was trying to just uh do some
touristing in this area so i go hit this
cave i'm caving
and um well first of all at one point
they take you it's a boat you go under
this part of the
ground or or whatever it is earth rock
and they they you basically have to duck
down inside
of the boat so you go first you walk
into the cave then you get in this boat
then you go down this little river and
they uh you get down you have to go
under the rock and you literally have to
lay in the boat like if you put your
head up at all
you will die like there is a
like it's like 40 yards just straight
right like you can't even i can't even
believe they let us do it as just a
customer
you know because once i'm a customer bro
i kind of
you know i once i'm a customer dog
once i give you five or six dollars or
twelve dollars for an experience
i put my life in your hands
i kind of check out i just assume look i
gave them nine dollars bruh
i'm gonna be safe whatever i'm doing you
know
and it's a pretty sad it's a pretty
unfortunate and not
very you know it's kind of the opposite
i feel like of being like a navy seal or
a marine
it's like being like a um like a navy
skunk or something you know just
it's like i'm not really looking out for
myself anymore you know
it's like oh look i trust you look i
gave you seven dollars here you know
you taking me into the bat caves i'm
gonna trust you're gonna take care of me
so i'm like on my phone and [ __ ] i'm not
even painting and literally almost died
like
so the boat goes under the rock we go
through the cave
it's nice it's fun it's you know it's
it's it's
you're kind of pretending that it's more
fun than it is
the guy's like hey here's a hole right
here that uh
you know this hole's from 1904 and
you're like holy [ __ ]
my grandfather could have seen this hole
you know just things like that you
and you you know i find myself asking
questions like
oh really that's not a question but
you know what i'm saying like
like saying things that i don't even
really want to say you know like oh wow
never would have thought of that at the
end of the thing
here's what happened at the end of the
thing the guy
says and i want to thank you guys for
coming today
and i want to also let you know that
um only like 30 years ago this entire
cave
was filled
with trash right he this whole tour he'd
been telling us
how beautiful the cave was and the
temperature and
how there's only one fish that comes
this little fish named anna
or something lil anna show up and she's
the only one that come in the cave and
they you know wears anna tonight he's
like shining a flashlight in the water
and all of this
cutesy stuff you know and i'm just in
the back like you know
oh really you know just you know i'm
being up
i'm being a customer i'm being a
customer that's what you do
i give you seven dollars you walk me
through the thing i say
no way and we and we and you know and i
don't die
and you get me back to where we started
and we go our separate ways
maybe i buy a gift at the gift store
usually i do
oh yeah at the very end he's like and
also i just want to thank everybody for
buying a ticket today
you know the caves used to be only 20
years ago these caves were filled
entirely to the top
with and then you start just rattling
off
just complete [ __ ] just like washers
and dryers petroleum
uh trash he's like people came from all
around to throw their trash in these
caves
he's like they even found half of a
mobile home in here
now where was the other half i don't
know
but uh and i'm like oh really
anyway bro it was just crazy that
basically what i toured was like a
hollowed out
landfill like basically somebody tricked
me
into touring out a hollowed-out landfill
in kentucky for about 13
so anybody out there that says you can't
start a small business
man get you a shovel
and get you some [ __ ] and get you a
square reader for your phone
and i bet you're gonna be good man i'm
just sitting
on your front porch wondering how could
i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
[Music]